congratulations
on not just getting a film done under
pretty impossible circumstances but a
really good one
thank you we survived yes we survived
i don't know for long but we did for now
i mean you're in a room together that's
kind of amazing uh
how i guess like how did you
at i you shot this in july of last year
is that right
i was so during the height of things so
how did you
decide that you you were ready and
willing to get back to work in that
period
i mean it was uh in france it was in
fact
right after the first wave so it was in
fact the lowest
uh point that we had and then the second
wave came
in september so the story is quite
uh um crazy because i i received that
script
um when i was finishing crawl i
fell in love right away but fortunately
i was already attached to
another project so i was going to only
produce the movie
and and then you know i was prepping
that other movie in canada
and then the covid uh came and the
economy uh
started and everything stopped and i
went back in paris and i think it was
exactly the same for you
you are working on another project and
in the lockdown
i realized that that script that moved
me so much
took like another meaning like another a
a
full uh uh um you know like kind of uh
deeper uh a stronger
existential you know reason to
exist because it was so much about what
we were going through
so as soon as the lockdown was uh
over in paris we just jumped into
pre-production and and we shot july
august
right after it went so fast in fact it's
it's pretty crazy
it's not the type of role you think of
having to do like physical
prep for necessarily but did you do
anything to prepare to be in a box for
that long
i did abs and i run for like a month
i was running lines and then i was
running
and then i was like getting ready to be
in that box and
and honestly when you train like three
hours or four hours a day
it's just like it's a you work on uh
the mental you know like as an athlete
you need to go to that box feeling like
feet healthy uh
i remember like i really needed to just
like take pictures of
the air like big space and uh and and
just like take
to that box with me like bring back all
those images of being like free and
breathing and having so much oxygen and
and
and it helped a lot i
can imagine did you
have to adjust your process of how you
break down a script because the demands
of this performance are so specific and
so face oriented
i mean when i read the script i was uh
i felt just honored i felt i felt that
was a gift i felt
you know like extremely challenging i
i didn't know if i was able to just like
make all the scenes right because i have
a big problem with rage and anger and
and i don't know how to act that i don't
know how to do that because i'm not good
at that in life
i'm i'm i'm better at crying uh
that's my easy button to put it to put
uh
but i was not claustrophobic i
i mean do i love rats i don't know but i
don't mind
having 200 rats with me living in my pod
same script in the water with crocodile
or spiders
would have been like a no for me a box
uh with a beautiful amazing part like
this
was a yes like just after i read it
it was just like so obvious that i
wanted to do something like this and i
felt
extremely lucky and and as alex said
like
after those the weird first first um
lockdown we felt so lucky to go back to
work and be able to actually make a
movie because august was like
different from you guys like august was
like a pose
in that coveted situation but every
movie we're like
should we go back how with which rules
and
most of those other movies had to go
back where they stopped
when we had to just like go from the top
and just like
start with the new rules and knowing the
new rules
when other movies were like we need to
do
is vfx we need to to rewrite everything
i remember that like yeah yeah yeah like
all those movies were like all the
rewrites situation
i mean like we were hearing like the
most insane uh
ideas of like we're going to shoot
actors on green screen and we're going
to
shoot the extra in a different set and
we're going to i mean that was like the
the the you know kind of like the
craziness that was going on about
how to make movie during the covet we
were pretty lucky because
we i mean we shot with mask we
respect all the the protocol of uh uh
social distancing and and all that but
we were very lucky that
no one got sick you know because we knew
also that
everything could stop from one day to
the next
but then to go back to the the creative
process and and the breakdown of that
movie
because of that continuity we were
lucky enough to shoot uh
in continuity and that was like an
amazing uh
uh you know like a privilege for for
for me as a director but also i think
for millennium for all of us
we were actually going scene after scene
and so we were with the character
discovering
the logical um you know like a
snowball effect of each decision of each
movement
and we could adapt the script as we go
into
you know making sure that everything was
tracking the right way
for for the right emotion because that
was so important for the story
from what i can tell the script is
pretty
close to the original script but of
course it was written in english and you
translated it over to french
um did much change in that translation
and did you did that process like
reframe
anything in the story for you uh
obviously you're
bilingual so you experience a lot of the
world that way
but it can be rather a transformative
experience to read something in another
language
it was a very interesting and new
process for me because
i always uh been writing my script in
in french and then i walk with a
translator
and other writer to adapt them in
english but i never did
the reverse and and the script was
amazing script in english and i start
working on the script
along uh christine leblanc wrote the
script
in english we actually developed the
script for months together
in english before taking the decision of
making the movie in french
and then that adaptation was not just a
simple translation
it was like an opportunity to open the
script maybe towards something a little
bit more
um mature and adult a little bit more um
you know like that kind of european uh
sci-fi
sensible sensitivity and and that was
like uh in the same time a great
challenge but also
a very rewarding process because it
anchored the movie into a much more
somehow real world uh even if everything
was in the script
it's just like that that kind of french
european
background brought like another color
another taste
to it when it comes to actually
being on set and accomplishing the
visuals of this
what kind of mechanics and techniques
did you and the dp use to
keep the sense of claustrophobia but get
the shots you needed and get as close up
as you needed
hi you know we we had to choose very
early on about the size
of the pod and and you know we were like
split in between
doing it like a a coffin size smaller
and that would have been more the one i
had a little bit smaller
okay but i could have the bigger one and
i didn't
that's not cool and so we went a little
larger because we wanted
all those medical screen to to be there
with her but also because i was
uh uh you know like so lucky to have
such an amazing performance
and someone i was like just creating
that continuity
that emotional continuity in that
journey through the wool movie into that
one set
i could afford to um change the style of
the directing
almost like scene after scene so we
actually opened the toolbox we took
all the different gadget and and gizmo
and
all the different type of lens and
camera
and and system to just change
the the the camera movement every day
not to just make something different but
to follow in a better way to underline
in a better way
all the emotion that our character was
going through
and and i remember every day on set you
know like when
melanie was getting into the pod into
that very small
opening like that she was like seeing
all those crazy
different type of camera different type
of crane a different type of track
or sometimes just the dp and held you
know
like standing belly above her with the
camera
it was it was a really interesting
process
and you might have thought that we were
crazy sometimes no
but uh that was uh it was funny sometime
i was like
lying down and he was like so the move
the the camera today is going to be
very um close to your face and i was
like okay
okay well that's super close okay wow
that goes
the camera like never stopped and it's
like
like touched actually my lashes and i
was like
you mean that close he was like yup
that's for today
how do you guys when your camera is that
close which obviously is not the norm
how do you guys communicate to ensure
like that your
expressions are on the right level it's
pure eye acting like she's uh she's a
pro
actor usually saying like
cry but just one tears from your left
eyes for example no
nobody you know what it was fun and it
helped me a lot like
i think i was really grateful for
working with a
director who first of all knew exactly
what he wanted had fun to do it also
you know and then you know like
when when a script is that challenging
for an actor the only thing you
hope if you give all of you it's just
like
to be in a good movie at the end because
if you just give it all
and the movie is not good it feels like
you've been betrayed you know and when i
was like and i was
i went to that set like blind i was like
of course
it's going to be great so i was like
extremely
confident about everything he was doing
but also
the fun part was that like the fun part
for me was just like to sitting in my
pot and having like you know like 10 15
minutes of explanation of like
that's how we're gonna work today that's
how we're gonna film everything and and
because i'm a director too we just like
loved sharing
everything i love technique i i learned
so many things
and it was fun like starting the day was
fun
then less fun at some point but but you
know like you start the day and you talk
about
the technique and you talk about the
emotions and then you know exactly where
you go and
it's pretty cool to work that way
when it comes to the performance of
milo what were you interacting with did
you
have recordings was it a live delivery
no that was live delivery and alex
was very delicate and he asked me
during prep he said um okay so what
about milo
you're gonna have someone what do you
want
do you want to choose that person who's
gonna actually lead you the whole movie
and just like be there with you and
you need to love his voice you need to
love that guy you need to love that
person because he's going to be in your
ear
the whole time and i thought that was so
delicate to ask me
because that was true like i i had the
chance to pick up my best friend
who's an amazing actor that i know since
like 20 years
and having like a friendly voice into my
ear
for like those five weeks was amazing he
helped me with the lines and then he
helped me
every day because when they were like
working on technique and working on
everything i couldn't leave the
pod because i had cables everywhere so
if i was leaving the pot that was only
for
peeing and and and that was the only
reason
i was i was supposed to stay there for
hours so having like
you know like a friendly voice who can
just like make jokes sometimes
and talk about things and and it was
just absurd
honestly it was absurd sometimes to be
able to just like
saying jokes and listening some music
and being like
dancing when everybody just around like
work on everything yeah
they are their own life because we we
build that very um
little uh soundproof shack
and he was staying in so he couldn't
hear what he was saying i was hearing
everything because
i wasn't he was hearing the stupid jokes
but no one else
they were like a real interaction
happening like a like almost like a
radio show and it was moving too
you know when you have your best friend
in your ear and then you just like have
to go through like emotions
it was just like nice so thank you
i'm always super intrigued by choices of
first
and final frames um so i'm curious about
you know the decision to start with the
rat
and end with actually letting people
have a little relief
my read is that the end is a bit
ambiguous on reality but you do give
people this
opening up a bit the the rat was
definitely something that
um i had it in the script like
you know like a really you know like uh
uh early not early on but like one of
the last changes we did uh
on the script and for me that rat
pass that rat allegory was kind of like
the most uh
important element to
speak about the character and and talk
about how
she's trapped into that mental maze and
at the end
i wanted this kind of uh very
like big scale opening that i mean
the movie at the end of the day is a
movie also
about you know life after death somehow
because
you know like if we in a spoiled land
the real character are both dead at that
point
but somehow they still survive somewhere
else so
it was that kind of reflection and i
wanted to
actually feel that kind of opening to
the world movie
where you start in that very narrow pass
with that you know lab rat like finding
his way
and then going with you know her
character melanie like
waking up in that shroud and tearing off
like a cocoon
and then by the end going back there but
maybe with
a positive outcome to that wall uh
german
i believe the uh original script ended
with a
fade to black which is kind of brutal um
this by contrast feels that it opens up
a whole
world like we get hints at what is
happening in this bigger
world uh was that was kind of a two-part
question was that something important to
you to like expand that world a little
bit
and the goofier question is like do you
think this for such a contained film
by opening up to space like that an
actual other planet do you think there's
a potential for sequels there
ah but not in a pod no in the water
no no like yes yeah
there there is i mean i i don't think it
was conceived as
a potential uh franchise with with a
sequel
but they were something so you know
what moved me and i think what also uh
got us
all very involved and excited the
project is almost that kind of romantic
side
of it you know it's also a love story
it's a love story that goes beyond
and the the reality of the element like
that
actual planet that exists uh who
actually doesn't you know turn
and has this kind of a permanent sunset
and that cold and hot side i thought
that all this was so romantic
in uh in a very i mean you can sounds
very cheesy
put out of the context but in that kind
of
conclusion of of that journey for for
for the characters and and
i don't know if if it's in her head
if it's real uh i
i feel i want to believe it's real i
want to believe that they managed to
to you know find that new place to start
i don't know if um if a sequel will be
like how they're going to build
a new society that will not destroy
everything right away
and and and and and maybe try to to do
things in
a in a better more um you know
soulful way i never thought about a
sequel actually
but let's do it let's wait the release
and then
let's see i really liked that choice and
it did
i think it takes it from the question of
does she survive
into my mind immediately went like well
then what happens if that's real i want
to see it
okay yes we're going to tell that to
netflix
yes we will come back to you thank you
guys so much for your time so much
thank you thank you thank you bye